I wrote it she sent it I'm
so I was out one night with a bunch of
friends and I ran into my ex-boyfriend
with this like basic blondes looking
very very but she was not cute right and
I wasn't there right I'm always there
then I get home and I'm like okay you
know what like I'm actually a little
upset like why did I not say hi you're
like right wrong it's 3:00 in the
morning right and then while I'm asleep
and just wake me up I'm typing it all
out and like it was really weird to see
you out like I don't think we should be
friends probably the opposite of what I
actually want it was obviously the
opposite of what you wanted I tell her
all the time like you do not text an ex
especially when you're drunk especially
when it's 3:00 in the morning oh my
gasps me but you didn't care was like
crying and then I'm just like okay I
don't eat you I don't know man you
always need me any no okay
probably best probably true so I press
send like what is he gonna save any
texture back and it says all good all
good all good who does that
I sends like this like this essay and
then I nuns do that now I have to send
another text and like Digg might be
gonna dig yourself out of the hole
obviously when you do something like
that and then you're like I'm right and
I gotta unpack it you know it's just
like forget what I said I was a little
emotional I also had to admit defeat and
like I'm emotion like okay I'm a little
psycho
right so I'm like okay like you know
just forget it ignore it like whatever
and then and then what do you say back
you said no worries period protip twin
knows best
you